salut je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
sortir un petit truc sur l'affaire de
pardieu je dis bien un petit truc je ne
vais pas explorer en détail les
ramification de ce qui se passe si je
devais expliquer tout ce qui m'énerve
dans cette histoire on en aurait pour 2
Hees il y aurait plein de choses à dire
surt ce que ça révèle de la culture
dominante mais je vais me concentrer de
rebondir sur un truc l'autre jour je
lisais un article dans Le Monde intitulé
l'affaire de par Dieu fracture le monde
de la culture comme d'habitude avec le
monde c'est méga mou du genou ça se
mouille pas des masses quoi et puis à un
moment je lis ça sopiane Benasser acteur
des amandiers de Valéria brunit deschi
accusé de viol l'instruction est en
cours c'est qu'on ne le fera plus jouer
aux dernière nouvelle il serait caissé
dans un cinéma à Rome cette dernière
phrase est lourde d'implicite et c'est
assez gênant je ne sais pas si on est
censé le plaindre de vivre à Rome et
d'avoir un job de caissier je ne sais
pas si le journal de monde a l'habitude
de laisser entendre que le métier de
caissier est indigne mais bon passons en
lisant ça j'ai pensé ah mais oui il
c'était passé quoi avec Sophian Benasser
déjà donc j'ai tapé son nom sur les
internets le premier truc que je trouve
c'est une tribune pour défendre
l'accteur paraî dans le point je laisse
ma curiosité prendre le contrôle et je
décide de lire là je tombe sur cet
argumentaire qui se veut malin et qui
est terriblement stupide en gros le viol
est un crime donc c'est à la justice de
trancher s'il est coupable ou non et
c'est exactement ce qu'on retrouve dans
la tribune qui défend de par Dieu il y a
tellement de trucs qui ne vont pas
là-dedans que je ne sais même pas par où
commencer j'ai l'impression que c'est
super rvélateur de la posture quiadopte
à chaque fois celles et ceux qui signent
des tribunes et des pétitions pour
défendre quelqu'un accusé d'agression
sexuelle alors je voudrais juste
clarifier deux trois choses à
l'attention des gens qui pensent qu'il
faut laisser la justice faire son
travail la première chose c'est que la
justice est là pour décider si un
individu est coupable du point de vue de
la loi c'est tout pas coupable dans
l'absolu pas du point de vue de la
morale pas du point de vue des relations
interpersonnel on n'attend pas la
justice pour savoir si un comportement
est acceptable ou non par exemple si
votre meilleure ami vous trahit s'il
vous ment s'il dit du mal de vous dans
votre dos la justice ne le déclarera
jamais coupable de rien mais on
comprendrait que vous disiez de lui
c'est un salot et que vous prémiez votre
entourage de ce qu'il vous a fait ce ne
serait pas un comportement bizarre bah
là essentiellement c'est la même chose
au fond dire qu'il faut laisser la
justice faire son travail c'est dire en
somme que la seule chose qui compte
c'est de savoir si l'individu a
transgressé la loi comme si une
situation humaine genre une interaction
conflictuelle entre plusieurs personnes
n'avait au fond qu'une seule dimension
qu'une seule réalité sa place
relativement à la légalité comme s'il
n'y avait rien d'autre en jeu dire qu'il
ne faut pas se mêler d'une affaire ne
pas se positionner dans un camp ou dans
l'autre tant que la justice n'a pas
tranché c'est affirmer que le sens de
l'affaire se réduit entièrement à sa
dimension légale c'est donc nié qu'une
affaire comme celle de de Part Dieu
engage des symboles et qu'elle a un sens
social un sens politique qui déborde le
seul cadre de la loi par ailleurs dire
qu'il faut laisser la justice trancher
c'est aussi considérer que la conclusion
que tirera la justice sera forcément la
bonne c'est donc en un sens nié que la
justice puisse se tromper pourtant c'est
pas l'exemple qui manque et puis c'est
également nié que la loi puisse être
injuste pourtant là non plus c'est pas
les exemples qui manqu la justice peut
bien faire respecter une loi injuste le
deuxième truc c'est que la justice est
là pour sanctionner les individus en
usant du pouvoir que l'État lui confère
c'est-à-dire que la justice parce
qu'elle ne se préoccupe que de l'égalité
ne sanctionne que sur le plan légal en
ce sens seule la justice peut décider si
on emprisonne de par Dieu ou non les
gens qui défendent de Part Dieu osent
parler de tribunal populaire comme si la
cancel culture mettait effectivement les
gens en prison ce n'est pas le cas la
justice a son pouvoir la vindicte
populaire en a un autre la justice peut
emprisonner le peuple peut boycotter ce
n'est pas parce que la justice a un
pouvoir de condamnation qu'elle a le
monopole de toutes les condamnations le
peuple n'a pas le pouvoir d'emprisonner
mais il a le pouvoir de stigmatiser
moralement un artiste il n'y a rien
d'illégitime là-dedans la justice doit
respecter la présomption d'innocence
parce qu'elle a le pouvoir de condamner
quelqu'un à la prison parce qu'elle a la
capacité de restreindre la liberté d'un
individu c'est ce point qui est super
important à rappeler la justice peut
porter atteinte aux droits fondamentaux
de l'individu c'est vis-à-vis de cette
atteinte à ces droits fondamentaux que
de par Dieu bénéficie de la présomption
d'innocence de l'autre côté l'unvindicte
populaire la stigmatisation morale de de
pardieu ça n'atteint pas ses droits
fondamentaux de Parieu continue de
bénéficier de la présempption
d'innocence même si le peuple le
condamne unanimement parce que la
condamnation symbolique du peuple
n'atteint pas ses droits fondamentaux le
boycot populaire n'atteint que ses
privilèges et ça n'a rien à voir
défendre de par Dieu alors que ses
droits ne sont pas en danger c'est
défendre ses privilèges c'est défendre
son statut de célébrité ce n'est pas
défendre ses droits de
citoyens peut-être qu'on peut
questionner la condition de personnalité
publique et le type de violence auquelle
ça expose mais ça c'est une discussion
qui demande des arguments sérieux et
rigoureux ça ne suppose pas de se
contenter d'affirmer que la justice doit
faire son travail le troisième truc que
je pense à ce propos c'est que cette
idée selon laquelle il faut laisser la
justice trancher semble dire quelque
chose comme vous n'êtes pas censé avoir
d'avis sur la valeur morale d'un
comportement sous-entendu tant que c'est
pas confirmé par la justice honnêtement
ça me semble clairement intenable
d'abord parce que ça suppose de donner
un crédit maximum à la justice genre
comme une autorité scientifique qui ne
se trompe jamais si le juge a dit qu'il
était coupable alors c'est sûr que c'est
vrai et maintenant qu'on sait que c'est
vrai on peut se permettre de se
prononcer franchement c'est pas très
convaincant ensuite ça me semble
intenable parce que même quand on n'est
pas sûr à 100 % de quelque chose on est
parfois obligé de se positionner je
vrais proposer une petite expérience de
pensée pour mettre ça en perspective
trois de vos amis vivent en colocation
Alice Bob et Carla Alice vous apprend
qu'elle a porté plaintte contre Bob pour
cou et blessures comment réagissez-vous
c'est-à-dire quel comportement
allez-vous adopter vis-à-vis de Bob et
vis-à-vis d'Alice est-ce que vous allez
continuer à voir Bob comme si de rien
nétait est-ce que vous allez continuer à
passer de bons moments avec lui vous
n'avez pas lui posé de questions vous
n'alz pas lui demander de vous raconter
sa version des faits est-ce que vous
allez aller dire à Alice que vous
comptez attendre la décision de la
justice cela ne revient-il pas à
affirmer que vous ne la croyez pas parce
que si vous la croyez si vous pensez que
Bob a effectivement agressé Alice alors
il serait logique que votre comportement
vis-à-vis de lui change peu importe que
la justice n'est pas encore rendu son
verdict non si vous croyez Alice et que
vous continuez à être pote avec Bob
comme si de rien n'était on comprendrait
qu'Alice ne ve plus être votre ami non
et si Carla vous dit que Bob est en
effet agressif parfois est-ce que vous
allez continuer de penser qu'il faut
attendre la décision de la justice ou
est-ce que vous allez enfin commencer à
condamner moralement le comportement de
votre pote Bob si après des mois
d'attente la plainte n'aboutit pas que
faites-vous vous décidez de rester pote
avec Bob quitte à perdre les amitiés
d'Alice et de Carla que la plainte
n'aboutisse pas vous autorise-t-il à
rester pote avec Bob comme si de rien
n'était et dans ce cas comment ne pas
penser que vous faites le Paris de
soutenir le potentiel agresseur et de
dénigrer la potentielle victime il faut
rappeler pour le cas de de pardieu que
ces défenseur en en attendant que la
justice se prononce ne ni pas vraiment
les problèmes liés à son comportement
personne ne pense sérieusement de par
Dieu il a jamais dérapé il a un
comportement irréprochable on ne
s'attarde pas sur son comportement on
préfère parler d'art de son talent de
comédien on voit bien qu'on ne peut pas
défendre sérieusement l'hypothèse selon
laquelle de Part Dieu serait victime
d'une énorme calomnie donc à partir du
moment où il y a plusieurs personnes qui
se plaignent du comportement d'un
individu on ne peut pas faire comme si
on avait pas entendu des plaintes c'est
comme ça c'est la vie ça vous semble
peut-être inconfortable mais c'est comme
ça si si les gens se plainent du
comportement de quelqu'un et qu'il
s'agit de quelque chose de grave vous ne
pouvez l'ignorer et vous devez vous
positionner vis-à-vis de la situation
vous ne pouvez pas faire comme si ça
n'existait pas vous ne pouvez pas faire
comme si c'était impossible vous devez
choisir est-ce que vous condamnez le
comportement est-ce que vous le
condamner moralement est-ce que vous
décidez de croire que tout le monde ment
et si vous pensez qu'il est innocent que
tout le monde ment il va falloir le
justifier qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on
défend la potentielle innocence de
quelqu'un accusé par plusieurs personnes
de les avoir agressé
est-ce qu'en faisant ça on adopte une
position neutre si vous dites à Alice et
Carla que vous ne supportez pas de voir
Bob accuser ainsi de telles horreurs et
que vous allez attendre que la justice
fasse son travail ne croyez-vous pas
qu'elle serait légitime à ne plus
vouloir vous parler à dire à vos
connaissances commune que vous êtes le
pire des amis c'est pas très différent
de ce qui se passe ici on ne met
personne en prison là ni de Part Dieu ni
ceux qui ont signé cette tribune c'est
pas très compliqué à comprendre pourtant
dans l'article du Monde Charles Berling
exprime son désarroi
on vit dans une drôle d'ambiance on est
d'un bord ou de l'autre il n'y a pas
d'entre deux possible les gens refusent
de se parler moi je voudrais parler
qu'on parle la Canel culture je peux
plus supporter et là je me retrouve avec
effacé Berling c'est fou autant de
mauvaise volonté qu'est-ce que tu
comprends pas Charles il y a un type
dont le comportement transpire la
culture du viol dans tous les sens et
quand les gens le dénoncent tu Sines un
papier pour le défendre qu'est-ce qui
t'échappe il y a des gens qui disent que
de par Dieu les a agressé et toi tu
signes un truc pour dire n'attaquez pas
de par Dieu tu comprends pas
qu'enseignant tu cches à la gueule des
victimes quen signant tu dis à tes
autres collègues comédiens prédateurs
qui sont soutenus qui peuvent continuer
à se comporter comme ça et après tu dis
je voudrais parler mais tu pouvais pas
parler à Gérard et lui dire que son
comportement est inadmissible allez je
m'arrête là sinon je vais encore me
laisser déborder en tout cas n'hésitez
pas à partager à liker à vous abonner
tout ça si ça vous a plu à
bientôt